if you put eggshell in water it will
sink down to the bottom where it belongs
but if you take some eggshell and treat
it kindly with dignity and a little bit
of
romance Watch What
Happens it refuses to sink that is the
Power of
Love or is it nope it's that the blunt
end of an egg comes with its own
built-in flotation device an air sack
between the membranes after an egg is
laid and starts to cool and dry out this
air sack gets bigger it gives the embryo
room and air to breathe before it
hatches and breathes the outside air as
well as room to position itself prior to
hatching the older the egg the bigger
the air sack will be and the more it
will buoy up any shell attached to it
it's not magic it's not love it's the
uplifting power of the
[Music]
sack